mouna belani is one of the few women in
india who speak openly about being
infected with HIV she's lived with the
virus for twenty years her husband and
son both died from complications of AIDS
the government HIV program started just
in time for her medical treatment and
free drugs have saved her life
I could transmit my virus to other
people the trucks are helping Myrna
belani to live a normal life her oldest
son Mohit is HIV negative but has still
suffered other children were not allowed
to play with him he also feared losing
his mother for Moana the social
exclusion is almost as bad as the
illness itself
he saw my fight with the society he saw
my fight with myself because he is the
witness since childhood like how I am
suffering with my health sometime how I
am struggling with my work and my health
and my routine duties of towards my
family just over two million people in
India a living like Mona with HIV the
government is making a concerted effort
to combat the epidemic with some success
the number of people infected with HIV
has halved since 2010 one reason for
this is that India does not recognize
the patents filed by Western drug
companies more than half of AIDS
patients receive free medication
produced in India I won't call it copy
we call it reverse engineering so I
think India believes in access to
treatment for everybody and therefore
whatever is necessary good quality
treatment is available generic drugs are
available so cost really goes down
drastically mona Palani takes part in a
support group in Delhi
she tells young HIV patients they need
not fear for the future with treatment
they can even have healthy children
I lost my younger son due to that
because I was not aware that I had to
test him during my pregnancy or after my
delivery so it was lack of knowledge to
me the battle against the HIV virus has
certainly not been won in India but
there has been significant progress not
least thanks to people like Mona belani